bien bonjour à toutes et à tous pardon
c'est un peu fort excusez-moi l'énergie
vitale parce que les vacances arrivent
bienvenue pour ce point presse pour
commencer ce point parce nous souhaitons
avec beaucoup de solennité témoigner
notre émotion et notre solidarité auprès
des habitants de bagdad qui ont été
extrêmement durement frappée par cet
attentat et par le terrorisme islamique
on voit qu'il est malheureusement
présent sur l'ensemble du pays de la
planète et avec beaucoup de solidarité
nous indiquons notre émotion qui
semblerait qu'il y ait déjà plus de 200
morts c'est terrible et évidemment cela
nous rappelle que personne est à l'abri
et les français évidemment ont payé le
prix pour le savoir sur l'agenda
cette semaine
le président des républicains se rendre
à une fête départementale ce samedi à
brumath
à côté de strasbourg et puis un petit
clin d'oeil bien sûr pour notre équipe
de france je dis nous serons tous et
toutes
derrière eux pour les soutenir à
marseille face à nos amis allemands que
nous espérons malgré notre amitié
évidemment battre
je vais passer la parole à guillaume
merci beaucoup à léry bonjour à tous
quelques mots d'abord pour revenir non
pas sur le match d'hier soir qui fut
fameux mais sur notre conseil national
de samedi dernier qui a démontré une
fois de plus et je peux vous dire que
pour nous tous qui sommes des élus dans
nos territoires
tous les témoignages les remontées de
terrain des quelque 2000 conseillers
nationaux qui étaient présents sont tous
unanimes pour dire leur fierté
d'appartenir à une formation politique
debout qui a retrouvé justement la
capacité à porter un projet rassembler
l'ensemble de la famille à assurer et
assumer un grand nombre de victoires
électorales
on le répète mais c'est très important
de le dire et de le répéter de notre
part puisque parfois les commentateurs
l'oubli un peu trop facilement depuis la
la l'élection de nicolas sarkozy à la
tête de notre famille politique
ce sont ce furent des victoires aux
élections départementales aux élections
régionales la quasi-totalité des
élections partielles qui ont vu la
victoire de l'un des nôtres et c'est
très important de le dire parce qu'au
delà des victoires électorales
au delà du grand nombre de militants
d'adhérents et de sympathisants qui nous
rejoignent
puisque nous sommes est de loin le
premier parti de france 265 mille
adhérents à jour de cotisation et tout
cela sous le contrôle d'un huissier nous
sommes aussi désormais une famille
politique en ordre de marche sur le plan
programmatique
il n'y a pas et encore moins 21e siècle
qu'avant il n'y a pas de formation
politique digne de ce nom qui n'est pas
capable de présenter de porter et
d'incarner un projet politique un
programme de gouvernement d'alternance
et d'alternatives et c'était tout
l'objet de ce conseil national et à la
cazine
limité des conseillers nationaux notre
formation politique à adopter son projet
pour 2017
tout est là il a pu être exposés tout au
long de cette de cette journée donc
victoire aux élections programme abouti
et l'ensemble des conseillers nationaux
des adhérents des sympathisants des élus
de terrain se sentent très associé
puisque ce fut le fruit est le produit
de 18 conventions thématiques le
résultat de plus de 350 mille votes par
internet et l'association de toutes
celles et ceux qui avaient envie de
participer justement à l'élaboration de
ce projet il ya aussi la victoire sur le
plan financier nous revenons de loin et
tout le travail qui a été mené par
nicolas sarkozy par daniel fasquelle et
l'ensemble des élus et des dirigeants de
notre parti tout cela a permis
aujourd'hui d'avoir un parti sain sur le
plan financier et c'est pour cette
raison d'ailleurs que la primaire qui
s'annonce de la fin du mois d'août
jusqu'au 20 et 27 novembre prochain
pourra être financée grâce justement au
soutien et à l'apport des des
républicains donc c'est important de le
rappeler parce qu' un parti uni un parti
qui présente un socle programmatique à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et de nos
compatriotes est bien aussi c'est la
preuve que le premier parti d'opposition
le premier parti de france aujourd'hui
sont en capacité d'assumer et d'assurer
l'alternance et l'alternative que mérite
la france et que à laquelle aspirent nos
compatriotes sur et puis un dernier
point d'ailleurs toujours là dessus tout
les élections législatives ou avec tes
commission d'investiture se réunissent
depuis le début du mois de juin
et à l'heure où nous parlons sur les 577
circonscriptions 555 ont été étudiés et
seulement 9 font l'objet d'une
candidature et d'une investiture
réservés c'est donc bien la preuve là
encore que l'art du compromis la
capacité à incarner le consensus autour
de notre président nicolas sarkozy et de
l'ensemble des cadres et élus de notre
formation politique
par delà les
les petites polémiques c'est bien la
preuve là encore que notre parti est en
ordre de marche à c'était le premier
point que nous souhaitions évoqué
collectivement devant vous ce matin deux
sujets d'actualité très rapidement mais
mais très important d'abord nous avons
été nombreux
comme nos compatriotes à être étonné
d'abord choquée ensuite lorsque nous
avons découvert sur al'approche vous
avez des oraux de rattrapage du
baccalauréat
cet écrit cette circulaire émise par la
maison des examens d'île de france qui
recommandait à l'ensemble des
organisateurs de ces examens de reporter
de 24 heures en raison de questions
communautariste et religieuses les oraux
de rattrapage et ce matin nous voulons
nous solennellement demandé à najat
vallaud belkacem d'intervenir de mettre
fin à cette circulaire est de condamner
ce type d'attitude
il n'y a pas de place dans notre
république pour toutes les
revendications communautaristes et il
nous faut affirmer haut et fort les
valeurs de la république
le baccalauréat c'est une épreuve
nationale et au nom de cette épreuve
nationale nous devons faire respecter
partout et en tous lieux les lois de la
république et donc il était
indispensable de le dire et de le
rappeler tant cette circulaire symbolise
une fois de plus non pas simplement une
entorse men atteinte grave parce que
répéter à la laïcité et nous sommes tous
témoins quotidiennement dans nos
établissements scolaires sur le terrain
dans nos communes de ses tentatives
d'atteinte à la laïcité
si les élus de la république c'est le
gouvernement ne sont pas en capacité de
rappeler avec autorité avec pédagogie
avec fermeté qu'il n'y a qu'une seule
loi qui doit être respectée sur le
territoire de la république
alors le communautarisme finira non pas
simplement par gangrener mais par abîmer
l'esprit et l'unité de la république
dans le même esprit même si c'est
évidemment pas la même question est pas
le même domaine
nous nous savons et vous le savez que
manuel valls emmène une délégation de
deux ministres aujourd'hui en corse et
nous avons été aussi particulièrement
étonné par les propos de manuel valls et
de son entourage sur le rapport entre la
corse
l'état et la république d'une part nous
avons été scandalisé par les propos
répétés de monsieur talamoni qui dit ce
matin encore dans le parisien
aujourd'hui en france que la peau la
corse n'est pas française oui la corse
est française
oui la corse et dans la république et
oui la république est partout chez elle
en corse il est indispensable de le
rappeler il est indispensable de le
rappeler car personne n'oubliera jamais
qu'il y a un peu plus de 18 ans un
préfet de la république fut assassiné et
donc il est indispensable de à travers
la mémoire de ceux d'un des crimes les
plus odieux les plus graves qui aient
connue notre pays que nous soyons nous
et de la république là et c'est le
devoir et le rôle du premier ministre de
rappeler que la corse ne fait pas figure
d'exception que nous souhaitions toutes
et tous nicolas sarkozy l'a largement
démontré depuis une vingtaine d'années
défendre promouvoir l'identité corse
c'est une chose mais l'identité corse ne
peut s'exprimer que dans l'unité de la
république et que dans l'unité de la
nation française
voilà nous voulions rappeler à travers
cette visite du premier ministre
eh bien les principes fondamentaux que
nous souhaitons nous défendre
chez les républicains à toi cher
philippe
il ya sur l'agenda européen il ya eu la
semaine dernière une session plénière
extraordinaire du parlement à bruxelles
suivi d'un conseil européen le 27 et le
28 et nous nous réunissions à strasbourg
à partir de ce soir qu'elle a été
évidemment le sujet principal de ce ou
ces réunions c'est évidemment le bric
site avec toute la question de savoir
comment fixer l'attitude des européens
vis-à-vis des britanniques
la position des républicains est claire
il y à une sortie qu'il faut assumer
rapidement des britanniques
les périodes intermédiaires seraient
période absolument est plus terrible
deuxièmement pas de négociations avec
les britanniques avant que la sortie ne
soit formalisée par l'application de
l'article 50 ans vous savez que les
britanniques souhaitent
d'une certaine manière à la fois ne pas
sortir trop vite mais négocier très
rapidement même nigel farrage le
monsieur équipe au parlement européen a
pris la parole la semaine dernière et
après avoir dû beaucoup de mal de
l'europe durant la campagne a expliqué
très tranquillement qu'il souhaitait que
la grande bretagne continuent à
bénéficier du marché unique pour nous
les républicains les choses sont claires
on ne peut pas être dehors et vouloir
bénéficier des avantages du dedans donc
le marché unique
il pourra être ouvert aux britanniques
seconde herman à condition que ceux ci
respectent un certain nombre de
conditions qui leurs seront fixés après
négociations les en tout cas pas
davantage du dedans en et en dehors
en tout cas dans un premier temps je
veux faire remarquer qu'il ya une
déclaration du premier ministre slovaque
monsieur fico qui a la caractéristique
d'être le futur président en exercice et
monsieur fico a dit que c'était hors de
question que deux ou trois pays visant
la france essentiellement puisse fixer
la ligne en europe
et là on a la conséquence par cette
déclaration de l'absence totale de
françois hollande depuis plusieurs
années qu'il ya des habitués l'europe à
la présence de la france
la déshabille tuation de l'europe à la
france fait qu'aujourd'hui
eh bien tous les pays déclare que le
poids de la veulent le poids de la
france là sa vision sa voix n'ont pas
d'importance
et donc on voit très bien que
il ya un grand travail à refaire de
reconstruction de l'influencé française
en europe qui a beaucoup payé de ses
quatre années de françois hollande
et si j'ai un choix à faire pour le
match dans quelques jours c'est que le
couple franco-allemand soit rééquilibré
très rapidement également en matière de
football
donc sur ce conseil européen voilà le
voile à l'actualité il ya un deuxième
point qui qui nous est sorti d'actualité
hier soir puisque manuel valls a déclaré
très tranquillement que ils allaient
décider de ne pas appliquer la directive
travailleurs détachés alors on a
plusieurs commentaires à faire là-dessus
premièrement il faudrait que le premier
ministre nous explique comment il fait
pour ne pas appliquer une directive
parce qu'une directive c'est la loi met
le deuxième point c'est qu'en disant
cela ils pointent du doigt les
insuffisances de la directive les
insuffisances auxquelles nous voulons
remédier cela fait des mois que les
républicains expliquent que cette
directive détachement des travailleurs a
créé un dumping social et salarial qui
est totalement inacceptable pour la
france et on a l'impression que premier
ministre se réveille alors il se
réveille d'une manière assez curieuse
parce que la directive de 96 qui est en
phase de reno gal renégociation fait
l'objet de travaux actuellement au
conseil et au parlement européen et en
tant que parlementaires européens
je n'ai jamais entendu les représentants
du gouvernement français à bruxelles
représentants au conseil prendre une
quelconque position sur 7 sur cette
directive est donc je suis très surpris
de cette distance entre des déclarations
politiques du premier ministre qui joue
les gros bras en france mais qui à
bruxelles est totalement silencieux nous
attend donc la france exprime au conseil
les positions que premier ministre
exprime dans les médias on voit bien là
cette différence d'apprécier des
différences ces déséquilibres qu'il y a
entre des positions très très très très
martial française mais en fait toujours
cette absence dans les institutions
européennes je rappelle que sur la
directive détachement des travailleurs
des la position des républicains est
très simple mettre fin d'un ping social
mettre fin au dumping salarial mettre
fin au dumping social ça consiste tout
simplement à dire
il faut que les travailleurs étrangers
qui viennent travailler en france n'est
pas un avantage concurrentiel en matière
de cotisations sociales ce qui est le
cas aujourd'hui par une surtaxe sociale
enfin la machinerie on la mettra en
route
peu importe en tout cas le principe doit
être accepté or aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
le cas et en matière de dumping salarial
on considère aujourd'hui qu'il ay à
différentiel de 50% en moyenne entre les
salaires versés un travailleur français
en france et un travailleurs détachés
qui vient travailler en france un
différentiel de 50%
ce différentiel doit disparaître et nous
y travaillons aux républicains enfin
dernier point le premier ministre dans
ses déclarations martiales doit pas
obliger oublier que la france est aussi
un exportateur de travailleurs détachés
nous sommes le troisième pays ex potain
exportateurs de travailleurs détachés et
donc c'est un sujet qui est suffisamment
important pour qu'on en fasse pas une
affaire de petite phrase qui resteront à
l'état de petites phrases nous attendons
maintenant je vais lire attentivement
cette semaine les déclarations de la rp
représentation permanente à bruxelles et
voir si on a la traduction dans les
instructions du gouvernement de la
déclaration du premier ministre hier
pour les affaires européennes de cette
semaine merci merci philippe revenons
sur le territoire national avec cette
annonce ce week-end par le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste sur
cambadélis de la suppression de leur
université d'été transféré de la
rochelle à nantes suppression indiqué
pour raison de troubles qui pourraient
survenir
cette suppression de nous amène deux
commentaires face à ce que nous
qualifions réellement de grand chelem du
recul du recul du parti socialiste le
premier recule c'est face à l'autorité
comment peut-on admettre dans un pays
qui est la france un pays de démocratie
que 200 ou 300 personnes violentes
ultraviolente d'extrême gauche puisse
monopolisé qu'annabelle cannabis ont
cannibalisé par dont un territoire à
leur profit et empêcher une formation
politique
démocratique qui si elle n'est pas la
première de france est néanmoins
représentative de tenir sa réunion
annuelle
comment cela peut-il être acceptables et
acceptées et comment le premier
secrétaire ne peut seulement le proposer
c'est un recul majeur dans notre
démocratie deuxième recul ce qu'il nous
semble également être exprimés derrière
ce report ce retrait d'exercice c'est la
volonté aussi de faire en sorte que les
frondeurs ne puisse pas s'exprimer et il
nous apparaît aujourd'hui clairement que
derrière cet affichage de recul
d'autorité il ya aussi la volonté de ne
pas permettre un certain nombre de
membres du parti socialiste de
s'exprimer et on cède face aux casseurs
pour éviter les frondeurs cela semble
assez étonnant voire affligeant et pour
tout dire nous choque dans une
république où l'ensemble du parti
socialiste à commencer par le premier
ministre qui est chef de la majorité
nous expliquent à longueur de journée
qu'il ne faudra jamais reculer sur le
terrain de l'expression de la démocratie
et de la parole nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui indiqué que nous ne sommes
pas dupes du recul d'autorité et de la
volonté aussi de faire en sorte que les
fondeurs n'est pas capacité d'avoir un
auditoire et une capacité de s'exprimer
pour terminer enfin
nous avons appris en fin de semaine
dernière suite à une visite du député
thierry solère à la prison de fleury
mérogis que le terrorisme salah abdeslam
aurait quatre cellules mises à sa
disposition
avec une qui aurait été transformée en
salle de sports pour son unique
utilisation nous le disons avec
solennité cela nous choque
cela nous choque beaucoup vous savez
tous il manque plusieurs milliers de
places de prison en france
de nombreux détenus sont entassés à
plusieurs
certains d'ailleurs sans ligne avec
uniquement des matelas par terre
or on privatise pour une seule personne
quatre cellules et une personne qui par
ses activités terroristes a évidemment
amené la mort sur notre territoire
nous sommes extrêmement choqués nous
interpellons le ministre de la justice
pour qu'ils nous indiquent au nom de
quel droit une personne peut se
retrouver effectivement de m mise dans
cette situation et quelle est la
justification qui fait que alors que
l'ensemble des français et bien payent
leur cotisation pour aller faire du
sport
monsieur salah abdeslam va pouvoir peut
faire du sport tranquillement seul dans
une cellule qui est privatisée pour lui